же шокуюча інформація в офісі президента
Уявіть собі невідомо скільки там працює
людей Ця інформація є воєнною таємницею
держави такою ж секретною як і кількість
наших збройних сил України але руху
чесно вдалося з'ясувати що цих людей є
аж 80 порадників радників які зранку до
вечора на волонтерських засадах Там
працюють тому що офіційно їх там немає
але от вони такі волонтери що сидять в
Марафоні керують країною все на світі
коментують вони розповідають про
Верховну Раду України про армію вони
обіцяють країні що там ще два-три
обстріли і все будет хорошо що у нас
два-три тижні і каву вони будуть пити в
Криму тобто несуть всяку пургу ні за що
при цьому не відповідають невідомо за що
живуть в цей же час наші партнери МВФ
Європейський союз Сполучені Штати
справедливо зазначають що корупція є
однією з ключових проблем яка роз'їдає
сьогодні державо і з нею треба разом
боротися І в цей час журналістські
розслідування виходять які говорять про
те що і офіс президента є таким джерелом
корупції наприклад заступник голови
офісу президента пан Шурма продає чи він
чи там його близькі електроенергію на
окуповані території на сотні мільйонів
гривень по суті спонсоруючи російську
федерацію і бойовиків і за це немає
жодної відповідальності пані доповідачка
правильно говорить що в нормальних
країна патронатні служби не декларуються
але Україна сьогодні
офісно-президентська Республіка в нас
Голова парламенту який є другою людиною
в парламентсько-президентській
Республіці по дзвінку з офісу президента
не випускає опозицію відрядження блокує
в опозицію під час міжнародної
діяльності у нас Прем'єр виконує всі
вказівки офісу президента в нас
нещодавно президент зустрічався з
журналістами і просив їх не розповідати
про корупці і оцими багатомільйонними
бюджетами політичної цензури про що
можна А що не можна говорити оцими
позитивними блогерами які живуть на
конвертах з ними розпоряджаються
позаштатні радники офісу президента і
Пані доповідочка яка є журналістом За
освітою це чудово знає що і це є
ненормально коли канал медведчука 1+1
наприклад сьогодні в Марафоні продовжує
віщать за державні кошти а політикою
займається навіть не цей канал
медведчука позашта
радники офісу президента як в найкращі
часи медведчука дають темники кого можна
показувати там А це радники офісу
президента А кого ні А це опозиція яка
навіть не має права сьогодні розказати
про і законопроекти які ми приймаємо і
тому Ми дуже хочемо щоби Україна була
цивілізованою державою щоби всі ті люди
які сьогодні дійсно здійснюють державне
управління державою вони мали відкриті
декларації вони декларувалися вони були
пепами вони потім розповіли через кілька
днів після втрати влади про те так А як
вони жили ть років ніде не працюючи на
волонтерських засадах харчуючись
нектарами амброзією не отримуючи
зарплату як вони взагалі жили і як
змінювався їх майновий стан і саме тому
ми пропонуємо і просимо це підтримати
щоби 80 радників офісу президента Які
собою підмінили сьогодні уряд органи
місцевого самоврядування
На жаль вони впливають на голову
Верховної Ради який не може собі
дозволити вперше В історії українського
парламентаризму бути незалежним і
захистити парламент навіть сказати що
депутати - це не Туристи в полосатих
купальниках А це політики які здійснюють
важливу роботу в міжнародній дипломатії
Ми хочемо захистити І голову Верховної
Ради сьогодні друзі Він буде
декларуватися він буде пожиттєвим пепом
так може ті люди які по телефонному
праву йому дзвонять весь час і
розповідають що на кого тиснути робити
теж будуть декларуватися і